contrairement à 2011 la manche élira ses
sénateurs à la proportionnelle à un tour
jean bizet aura donc face à lui une
autre liste de droite celle de philippe
bas avec un risque de dispersion des
voix
c'est plutôt désagréable si vous voulez
parce que les grands électeurs votent
objet de faire un choix
mais nous sommes différents et donc par
conséquent nous sommes complémentaires
si vous voulez je pense que c'est une
richesse pour la manche d'avoir un
président de commission des affaires
européennes et un président de la
commission des lois
c'est ainsi que je présente que les
choses le président de la commission des
lois mise lui sur la défense des
territoires ruraux
élu sur la liste du maire à saint pois
dans le sud du département
il se veut le porte parole de leurs
revendications
avant l'été vous ne pensiez pas pouvoir
conserver ce groupe
aujourd'hui les choses ont changé
justement pourquoi vous pariez donc sur
la grogne des élus locaux
oui bien sûr il y à une réduction de 300
millions dès cette année les 13
milliards annoncé la diminution des
contrats aidés la taxe d'habitation
tout ça fait naître chez les élus
effectivement une très grande déception
pour partie puis une très grande colère
encore chez beaucoup d'autres
donc moi je vois sur le terrain pour les
rencontrer individuellement qu'il y a
une grande insatisfaction qu'il y a eu
beaucoup d'espoir qui a été porté en son
temps sur sur des politiques et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que forcément
quand on tape au porte-monnaie des
collectivités in fine et on tape dans le
parc au nez de nos concitoyennes et de
nos concitoyens
et alors que les nuages s'accumulent au
dessus de la majorité présidentielle
difficile de faire campagne sur le
terrain pour les candidats investis par
la république en marche aux sénatoriales
souvent en réceptacle de la colère des
élus et des corps intermédiaires
le premier ministre les a rencontrées
cet après midi écoutez ces quelques
réactions à la sortie recueillis par
géraldine ma voix l'eau il a répondu
surtout aux questions que nous on se
pose au contact effectivement et pas de
petits élus mais des élus de terrain des
élus locaux
et effectivement c'est bien d'avoir les
réponses en direct du premier ministre
lui-même
comment se présentait bien les
sénatoriales pour les candidats investis
par la république en marche comme ça
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour
tam la mission s'annonce difficile à on
le voit et oui effectivement le contexte
a bien changé en l'espace de deux mois
au mois de juillet justement françois
patriat président du coup nouveau groupe
un tout nouvellement créé était est très
optimiste ou l'écoutant le même si je
n'ai pas fait de chiffres des chefs et
si nous doublons le groupe
et oui donc doubler les effectifs c'est
elle a l'ambition qui étaient affichés
c'était d'arriver à une soixantaine de
sénateurs changement de ton hier sur une
radio avec le secrétaire d'état aux
relations avec le parlement christophe
castaner françois patriat qui le
président du groupe la république un
marche à l'assemblée parle d'une dizaine
de gains possibles de postes mais vous
savez l'électorat qui votent pour les
options note sénatoriales c'est un
lectorat qui a été choisie est lui un
moment où la république en marche
n'existait pas donc nous ne pensons pas
qu'il y aura un raz-de-marée en faveur
de la république en marche au sénat et
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de
révolution de palais au palais du
luxembourg
nous avons gagné la région contre la
gauche nous avons gagné le département
contre la gauche nous avons gagné les
principales grandes villes et moyennes
villes contre la gauche donc je pense
qu'on a la possibilité de faire un beau
score maintenant on n'a pas réussi j'ai
proposé l'union qui n'a pas pu se faire
pour des raisons essentiellement de
personnes on va donc avoir sac la droite
en ordre dispersé face à lui liste
dissidente lr mené par jean pierre
bataille mais aussi celle de la
sénatrice udi sortante valérie létard
elle aussi compte sur le renouvellement
des grands électeurs et sur son
expérience pour attiré sur ses listes
je suis la seule élue sortante ici nous
avons travaillé depuis longtemps à
composer une liste avec des nouveaux des
élus qui étaient présents mais qui ne se
représentent plus moi-même qui continue
en fait l'aventuré qui porte toujours
cette même philosophie
et pour charmer les élus les étiquettes
politiques ne font plus recette
avec sa liste vivre les territoires
l'écologiste l'a bien compris il faut
aussi des parlementaires au sénat des
sénateurs qui ne soit pas totalement
dans les jeux politiques nationaux et
dans les appareils politiques nationaux
et des éléments très fort comporte c'est
quand même de dire que le sénateur ou
les sénateurs parce qu'on espère
peut-être avoir deux élus qui seront
élus à partir de notre démarche seront
mandatées aussi ensuite sur les grandes
lois non pas par un appareil politique
nationale mais par les élus du
territoire
je vais pas vous raconter des histoires
dans l'élection en disant on va la
gagner on ne va pas la gagner cette
élection est la droite va la gagner et
la droite sera majoritaire au sénat
raison de plus pour renforcer le groupe
socialiste et pour faire venir au sénat
pour faire élire des sénateurs de gauche
qui pourront de faire ce contrepoids à
la droite qui de toute façon sera
majoritaire